you're like everywhere with your
Christmas come on mother outcue is
stepmother money and model we know your
favorite curse word is mother lover
mother lover I only like only your
favorite word
no I do my daddy mother you nothing you
gonna pay him top dollar to say them no
and you never just like all the stress
on your back burning so much there for
that assault mother so what is your
go-to curse word 27 times
that's the many times to kill me 24 28 I
like compound verse compounds like like
you know not you would say like that
like you know this Wow this doc you say
this is a symphony you know that kind of
thing I can add a little bit of texture
to in the hit man's bodyguard Ryan must
protect Samuel Jackson's character over
the course of 24 expletive hours so we
can only assume this r-rated duo got
pretty close right no you said you I
didn't know that so I heard of grind on
my floor children the old girl
I've never met them but I think father
did the same I had many many beliefs
confirms that he's an incredible
professional that we have an amazing
chemistry together which is just like
dumb luck to have that with somebody
you're blessing a little bit